A few days ago, we lost our beloved milk cow, Tulip.
It was sudden and unexpected.
She was her happy self one day,
and the next morning, we woke up to her passed away in the pasture.
To say we weren't ready is an understatement,
because Tulip has been a huge part of our life
since the very beginning days of our farming journey.
When I think about Tulip,
I'm reminded of our morning and night milkings
that we've had these past years
as my kids and I and all of us would gather around her to milk her.
And whether or not the kids were fighting or in a bad mood,
whenever they would get underneath her and start milking,
they would start to talk. There would be a spirit of peace,
of camaraderie. Our troubles,
it sounds silly, but they would kind of melt away.
Tulip taught me and Daniel and all our babies how to be farmers.
She was there from the very beginning of their lives until now.
They were so gentle and so calm
that I knew my kids were safe around her.
They Learned how to. To walk animals and push cows and shut gates.
But when she was done with kiddos,
she was done. You couldn't change your mind.
But she was a cow that didn't need a halter.
So we could come up to her wherever she was in the pasture,
and we could milk her. And she would just stand and
Wait until you're completely finished milking,
and then she would go on her way.
I also love that in the very coldest of winters,
in the mornings and the night,
she would gather us all together and get us outside.
She was so calm. All our chaos here on the farm.
In fact, when we got our cows at the dairy a few months ago,
we walked her down to see if she would like it,
to see what she thought. And within a few hours,
Miss Tulip was back in our front pasture.
So that we could see her and milk her everyday.
Because that's where she belonged.
We're going to miss her terribly.